holy month at islam's third holiest site
and the courtyards around the al-aqsa
mosque in the dome of the rock are empty
mass prayer banned to help stop the
spread of the coronavirus
usually tens of thousands of worshippers
many from the occupied west bank
would come here each day to pray the
effects are being felt
beyond this sacred site by the people
who live and work in the alleyways of
the old city
lockdown has already brought serious
hardship for rafat
he says business has fallen nothing as
customers save their money
and there's no familiar ramadan boost to
make up for it
we wait for ramadan the whole year
ramadan is different with its beautiful
atmosphere
there is a lot of work in ramadan but
this year there is no work
and there is no ramadan foot traffic is
down and thoughts of religious
observance are competing with anxiety
over jobs and finances
i am 60 i have never seen anything like
this
my son has six kids he has rent to pay
he's not working
how are they going to eat and drink
as of this week the israeli government
that controls jerusalem's occupied east
has allowed more types of businesses to
open but as well as unlocked doors
recovery requires customers as some
restrictions begin to be lifted
shopkeepers here talk about a gradual
return
of some economic activity but very
gradual especially
given how few people comparatively are
on the streets of the old city
and all of this thrown into relief by
the fact that ramadan
is usually one of the busiest times of
the year last year this was the scene at
damascus
gate as thousands headed into the old
city to pray at al-aqsa
this ramadan the walk or islamic trust
in charge of the mosque
is telling the faithful to stay away
we're in great pain right now this month
is alexa month
usually we have tens of thousands of
people coming to the mosque and it
reaches hundreds of thousands
but for the sake of people's health the
wakf decided to suspend the prayers
[Music]
and so the prayers are instead being
brought to the people
online and on television in the hope
that it will feel all the better to be
here for real
with those tens of thousands of others
for ramadan in 2021
harry fawcett al jazeera occupied east
jerusalem